Thank you. Well, when I was a little girl, uh,
We had this radio in our house. This thing was as big as a piece of
of
furniture. And I used to sit there on the floor with my
ear pressed up against the speaker and I would listen to my favorite
radio program. It was about this guy named Sergeant Preston and his dog, King,
And they used to have a dog team and they'd go running all over the Arctic righting wrongs and I used to
fantasize about how one day I was going to grow up and I was going to do those very
things. But of course life kind of got in the way a little
bit. And believe it or not, forty
years later, there I was standing on the outskirts of
Barrow, Alaska. Alone with an eight-dog team and we were going
to dog sled across Arctic America to the east side of Canada.
Well I just didn't get up one day and say, "Well, I guess I'm going to dog sled across
Acrtic America.
I'd actually spent about ten years in Alaska. And I had learned how
to dog sled, how to take care of my
dogs, and gone on a lot of expeditions to gain experience.
So when we left Barrow, Alaska on February 14, 1993,
I believed that my eight dogs and I were ready to go.
Now the way it works in dog sledding is you have a team of dogs, in this case I had
eight, and you put a harness on them; and on the end of the harness there's a line; and
the line goes back to the front of the sled; and the musher stands on the back of the sled; and you tell
those dogs what to do. So you don't have any leash or rein. You just
use your voice
to control the dogs. Well of course it's kind of tricky to figure out how to
make eight dogs do the same thing at the same time.
So you have what's called a "lead dog." And that's kind of, you know, the head dog, the
number one lead dog.
My dog was a dog named Douglas. And I called him Duggie Dog.
Duggie Dog was a big ole seventy five pound floppy-eared guy and he was
just happy go lucky. He'd do
anything I ask him to do. Duggie had a son
named Robert.
And as far as anyone knows,
Robert never did a single thing he was told in his entire
life. So why
is he in the team? Well, the bitter truth is I
didn't have much in the way of money, I needed eight dogs, I only had eight dogs, so if you're in my kennel,
You were going.
So.
So I took Robert along and I put him in the back of the team where I thought he couldn't cause any trouble
and to be fair to Robert he did work pretty hard.
So.
So off we went on our first day and our first day was absolutely spectacular. I mean,
everything went just the way it was supposed to go. And I'm standing there in camp that first
night. And I'm looking around and look at my dogs all snuggled
up
behind the sleds, my little red and white tent is waiting for
me and I'm looking around and I'm thinking, "You know, we're pretty isolated.
There's nobody else around us for a long ways." But that's OK
because you know I'm a person who really loves solitude and isolation.
And anyway I was so jazzed. I mean, my dream was coming
true! Well, I was going to be the first woman to dog sled across
the Arctic. No woman had ever done this alone before. And I had spent a couple of years
looking
for sponsorship. And no one would help us. No one.
So I borrowed every nickel it took to make this happen.
And not too long before we left I ran into my neighbor, guy named
Dave, I like to call him "Neighbor Dave."
And I told Neighbor Dave my woes about
money and Neighbor Dave, you know, he's this big guy. He's like 6' 4" and two hundred pounds and he
looks down at me and he
says, "Well what do you expect? You're five feet nothing,
weigh a hundred pounds soaking wet, and those eight dogs
of yours, are nothing but a bunch of clunkers.
Nobody believes in you and you're gonna fail."
Wow. Thanks, Dave.
So I'm standing there
in that camp that first night and I thought to myself,
"You cannot listen to people like Dave."
I thought, you know, these people they don't see what I see they don't feel what
I feel when I'm up here. And I'm looking at the sun in the western sky. And I'm
looking at the Arctic Ocean and this giant sheet of ice. And all this land frozen. And I think
about the power it took to make that happen.
My dogs and I have the same stuff in us, as what's in all of that.
And when I look at that,
I don't feel small, I don't feel weak. I feel full
of power like I can do anything. Well, I wasn't naive
enough to think that this is going to be a day at the beach. This was gonna
be a pretty arduous
thing. As it turned out there were going to be, there were
more storms in the Arctic that winter than there had been in recorded
history. So when a storm is coming, you need to
stop
before it comes. And you set up your camp and I would put
my dog sleds on their sides and then put the dogs behind the sleds out of the wind,
set up my tent, and I get in there and snuggle up with a
book and read. But it is not a time actually when
you can just rest because I would go out every four hours round the clock
and check on my dogs. Make sure they had enough food. And if it was so windy
I couldn't stand up,
I did that on my hands and knees. Well of
course, it wasn't all bad weather. We had
just so many spectacular days out there, it's so beautiful in the Arctic.
One day that stands out most in my mind is this one day right before we crossed
the Canadian
border. And I'm looking off to the south and there are these mountains.
And it's just got a little snow on it, it looks like scrimshaw, and the Arctic Ocean,
and the air was
so pure it had no smell. And so quiet.
There's no sound. It's just. Total. Peace.
And we continued along, we're sledding. We came around to this
beautiful big beach.
And it looks so perfect, looked like a superhighway right in front of us and I got this
idea. I thought I'm going to take Robert. My dog, Robert.
And I'm going to put him up in front beside my number one lead dog, Duggie Dog.
And I'm going to give Robert a chance to show that he can learn commands.
What could he possibly do wrong?
About five minutes later, we came around the corner and there up in a ravine off to the right
was a mother polar bear and cub.
They're about a hundred yards away and they're standing on this
beautiful white snow and this perfect blue sky behind them - it's like a picture.
And I thought, "You know, the dogs aren't even going to see her."
Well, Robert's a bit of a tourist.
And
And he just happens to look off to the right and he saw the bears. And so now he swings to the right
and he wants to go and visit the bears.
Now I'm sure that Robert thought those bears were dogs
because dogs really don't like bears. And I'm yelling at  Duggie, "Haw!" That means go left. "Haw, Duggie, haw!"
Because I'm trying to get Duggue to take us away from the bears. But now the other six dogs see
what Robert is seeing and they decide they need to go see the bears.
So now the whole team swung hard to the right and we are rocketing
across this frozen beach. I'm standing on the brake as hard as
I can but it's not working because there's only about an inch of snow on this beach. And there's
nothing for it to bite into. I'm trying to flip the sled over but I can't flip it over.
We are rocketing the across this beach; we get to the bottom of the ravine. Now the
ravine is full of hard packed wind blown snow. And
the brake bites and we jerk to a halt.
But now my lead dogs Duggie and
Robert are only about three feet from this
bear. And I'm like maybe sixty feet.
And I'm yelling at Duggie "Haw, haw." Go to the left. But he doesn't hear me it's just
total chaos. I have no control over anything that's happening. And this bear is
standing there looking at us and she is not happy.
And she looked at my dog Duggie. And
she ran towards him in kind of a false charge. She tried to stop before she
hit him. But actually the ravine was so slick that she
banged right into him and sent him tumbling to the bottom of the ravine taking the whole team with him.
She turned around and high tailed it back to her cub and when the dogs saw her running away,
they tried to chase after her but they couldn't quite get to her because of course the break is still
in
the snow.
And now this bear is getting really agitated, and the dogs are lunging and lunging and barking.
And she's getting more and more agitated and she starts to
drool. You would have to be there to see how much drool can come out of
an agitated bear's mouth.
Now.
This is like four water faucets going off at one
time. And then she starts wagging her
head and clawing at the snow.
And then she made this sound. "Haaa"
I'd always been told by native people, when a polar bear makes that sound,
they're getting serious. And you better be ready.
Amazingly I just got real
calm and everything around me started happening in slow motion.
I reached into my sled bag. And I pulled out my shotgun.
Turn off the safety. And I aimed it at her.
And I thought if she's going to hurt one of my dogs,
I'm going to shoot her.
And
then everything stopped. It just got totally silent. No
more barking. No more
hissing. Just silence.
And then the bear seemed to see me for the first time. She took one
step towards me and she looked at me with those coal black eyes.
Ah...my stomach just lurched.
And I stepped away from the sled. One step. And I held out my hand and I
said, "It's OK, It's OK, We're going to go now."
And I swear I heard that bear say to me in my mind:
"I don't want to hurt you I just want you to go." And with that. She
just walked to her den opening about seventy feet away and slipped inside.
And her little cub is running over there trying to catch up to
mama. And it got right beside the den opening, now it had had its
first lesson on how to be a big tough polar bear. And
it looked over at us and it went, "ha!"
[laughing]
And then it jumps inside and I never saw them again.
So I ran up, got the lines untangled and jumped on the sled and I said, "All
right. Let's go." I wanted as much distance between us and those polar bears as possible.  We didn't
stop for three
hours. And it took me three days
to stop shaking. We had many more
challenges on this journey. But somehow we always managed to rescue
one another. This journey took eleven
months. And then, my eight dogs and I went home happy
and healthy. I had wanted to prove,
by doing this journey, that my dogs and I were good enough.
So we weren't a bunch of clunkers. And together we did that.
But what I gained most was a profound respect for my dogs.
And for myself.
And as for Neighbor
Dave. Ah, who cares what Dave thinks.
Thank
you.
[applause]